[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous étiez pas
[Applaudissements]
la housse est signé el maghra lorsque
vous marchez dans son métier si bien
habillé
vous étiez si bien à tillé que je n'ai
pas pu empêcher
2 vous tendiez vous étiez
et j'ai pensé je vous avoue que je ne
pourrai plus jamais reprendre l'homme
j'ai dis parce que la vie de tous les
atouts là
[Musique]
et
vous étiez grand je vous ai vu ce jour
là vous étiez paix
le paddock
je mets au fond
eux n'en a pas discuté
et qui plaide pour inviter dans si vous
voulez moi je sais bien que vous n'allez
qui ont promis à mon père connaît mais
croyez-moi ce n'est pas tout moi j'ai
partagé avec lui
autour de jours
de soucis comprendre et peut être un
jour
[Musique]
vous étiez p 30 jours que ce soit
alors cette fois comme toujours il
reviendra
et je peux m'en balance moi
respect
l acquittement du rap ou et
ouah
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]